ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show my red nose is because I got
a sunburn it is not an indication of a
relapse on alcohol even though that
would be called for given the news
I think nobody could really blame me if
I decided to throw a decade of sobriety
away in the current climate I'm not
doing that however you know so it's a
Sun burn that's what it is
I was out today in a beach town in Los
Angeles and Manhattan Beach and I was
with a friend and we're walking around
and here's the deal in that with the
face masks you know we're all wearing
his chin straps because nobody wants to
put them over their face cuz they're
disgusting I mean they're gross you
breathe in them it's what are we doing
you can't get air see when you wear the
face mask you can't breathe it's 90
degrees so not breathing shouldn't be
part of the strategy to help the
sickness I understand in situations when
you're around people is the right thing
to do so I have it just so I could slip
it up if I need be if someone walking by
me looks particularly panicked or I have
to run into a grocer grocery store I
have that I put the mask up but
everybody you know I Manhattan Beach
people are not wearing masks
some people are jogging they're on bikes
here's the thing with the lockdown out
here in Cali it's busting at the seams I
mean people are on the road people are
out there going to the beach people want
out man they've been in their house it
is beautiful weather people spend a lot
of money to live here and they've had
enough does it mean coronaviruses fake
doesn't mean it won't kill you if you
get it doesn't mean that it's not
serious if you get it but people have
had enough domestic violence
is skyrocketing people are just which
I'm somewhat surprised I thought being a
domestic abuser was somewhat a fixed
personality trait like if you beat your
kids you beat your kids
it wasn't contingent upon them being
home more or less like if you hit your
wife you found time to hit your wife
that's what I thought literally that's
what I believed I had no everyone's like
domestic violence is skyrocketing I was
like why I guess people are becoming
domestic abusers during this period of
time I guess stresses are running high
the kids are around and I guess what
happens is every day day in day out the
nagging of the wife the the disrespect
of the kid after a while you start going
I start seeing the real you know limit
of words you start wondering you start
saying yourself you know words are
really not what I need at the moment I
need to give somebody a little reminder
who the boss says now it's not right but
that's happening and it's happening at a
startling how much domestic abuse is
going up it's odd I thought if you were
that guy you were that guy I guess maybe
it's that guy beating them more and
woman too I don't want to be I I want to
be inclusive
there are women also beating their
children and probably beating their [ __ ]
husbands and maybe beating their wives I
don't I don't want anyone not I don't
want anyone listening to the show to
think I'm saying that domestic violence
is primarily a man's thing there's tons
of proud women that also engage in just
flogging their family beating the blood
out of their family when things don't go
the way they want
so don't for a minute think I'm only but
it's largely male right I mean there I'm
sure that that's and that's going up
people are upset about that
domestic flights that's the big
conversation they're like the economy
that's the thing they always bring up to
like the economy we're heading towards
Great Depression all true by the way
all true I know I you want me to be
positive on the program and I've you
know you know I'll tell you about I had
a good burger today we'll get into that
later it's not all bad but we are
looking at I mean the statistics are not
favorable right so for me to say that I
would be you know lying it's other than
the economy people you know when we talk
about the cost of the lock down people
bring up suicide and domestic violence
and suicide goes up and I get that
suicide goes up and then also domestic
violence is going to just and this is
when you talk with people they go they
got job they go domestic violence is
going to occur and I'm like are you
hitting your Chile
what are you confessing to me but I
guess that's what happens I'm not
doubting it to lockdown in the beginning
I understood hey it's a new virus we
don't know what the [ __ ] going on I
still understand it I still it dude New
York is being ravaged and if you don't
know people in New York you're not
talking to people in New York you're
you're unaware of what's going on
there's people dying you know just like
23 year olds dying and then people go on
my facebook but that person at a
pre-existing could do it and I'm like
you 600 pounds you're on Facebook you
are a pre-existing condition what are
you talking about I got fat people
saying yeah well that guys probably how
do I beat you what so the idea though
the country is full of pre-existing
conditions you can disagree with the
lockdown or say we overreacted or say
that there's a better way without being
a complete idiot and not realizing that
there's people that are in body bags
okay but let's be on
roll roll setup roll getting a little
sick of it and we're busting at the
seams people are out in the beginning
you know human nature is funny because
in the beginning I understand
then cuz my whole thing was like hey
morally I don't want to in fact somebody
else that's an older person I perform
with a lot of people that are decades
older than me I don't want to infect
somebody that is diabetic or somebody
that's vulnerable or has MS or and kill
somebody because I'm gonna I'm an idiot
and I need to be out eating a Pokeball I
felt like that was that's a character
issue you know take a chill pill do some
Netflix calm down but then you know this
goes on and on and on and you're like
what the [ __ ] are we gonna do people are
running out of money they gave you
$1,200 there's no money left there's no
money anyway there's no money on the
outside we're gonna find that out soon
too but let's that's let's wait a few
weeks for that episode everyone's like
open it up it's like okay we'll see but
people are are and and the thing with
human nature is human nature is funny
you know whenever you give people the
the smallest idea that they're doing
something altruistic or or that they're
doing something for the greater good
they will literally justify any stay
that's when they'll just go and commit a
genocide if they think that they are
doing something that's for the good of
society and you just give them that you
go do this and police each other rat on
each other turn into citizen informants
turn into brown shirts run around like
the Stasi yelling at kids on skateboards
and pointing to people's faces it go
where it's your mask those are the
people that put you in the camp they are
those are the people that throw you in a
camp and and that's what you're seeing
human nature goes there within a few
weeks within a few weeks
people were relish
their new roles as the enforcers of the
quarantine they were calling the police
on their neighbors they were yelling at
children who were standing too close to
each other there were just anybody that
was having any public enjoyment out
there in the world they were gonna go
and try to rob them of that and now I am
running today I run with a cop running
with a cop and I'm starting to notice
that the police now after 911 everybody
got really important doormen in
buildings in New York thought they were
part of the Homeland Security Department
everybody thought they were important
just like you know now with the
essential worker and everybody's a hero
thank - he writes eight o'clock the hero
thank you who the heroes again we don't
even know the doctors did it make it 300
grand a year the nurse is the guide Home
Depot - well who's the hero door - never
the hero am ia hero can I be here I love
my house today can I be a hero hey I
went to Home Depot I bought something
can I be hero I go to the grocery store
who's a hero we don't know who's a hero
anymore I get it the nurses are working
hard I bought you food enough the point
is this the heroes are getting a little
out of control now they're getting out
of hand to hear it calling people heroes
apparently does something that's not
really that positive that's why you
never call your kids heroes cuz they
turn into monsters if your son or
daughter does something good you don't
sit down and go you're a hero
you don't say that do you no you say
good job Bobby
good job you shared with your sister you
don't go you're a hero because then
Bobby would turn around if I hey I'm a
[ __ ] I'm a hero mom I shared with her
and it's like well no Bobby that's what
you should do no I'm a hero I mean so
the tick-tocks and I get it to blow off
steam but it's highly inappropriate
highly inappropriate wildly
inappropriate to blow off steam and many
nurses agree with me many of them there
are guests at the behavior of some of
these nurses
and and I'll say it again to delivery
people that are not getting the food to
the homes in time are not behaving in a
heroic manner door - is not behaving in
a heroic matter they're not so the
reality is we got to be a little careful
that word cuz we throw it around we
throw it around after 9/11 every cop and
firefighter was a hero every cop and
then they started choking black people
out because they were having cigarettes
industry so let's be careful with the
word hero there are real heroes but it's
an individual thing you know when you
brand everyone in here everyone's a hero
that's you know so I bumped into one of
those heroes today in Manhattan Beach
one of the heroes out there on a go-cart
being being heroic on his little go
carton guarding Manhattan Beach guarding
the wealthy hamlet of Manhattan Beach
California okay whose biggest crime is
when a seagull bothers someone like
Manhattan Beach they would they file a
report for like an aggressive seagull
that's that's the type of community this
is okay a [ __ ] Shack in Manhattan
Beach is six million dollars okay now I
like Manhattan Beach because I like
wealthy Hamlet's that I cannot be
legally kept out of which is Manhattan
Beach I they have to let me come there I
patronize the restaurants I know the
owners of the restaurants there's a lot
the best seafood restaurant in LA is
immanent Beach it's called fishing with
dynamite we go there all the time and I
and I they have another restaurant down
there and I hunted it I hunt III hunted
them down and I kind of walked into
their other rest
and I was like what's hey when's the
other one opening and they were like it
one lady was British it's coming soon I
was like good and I guy got food from
their sister restaurant for fishing with
Dynamite's great and so I'm in Manhattan
Beach and there is no cars on the road
um and I'm with a friend of mine there's
no cars on the road and there's a
there's a red hand signal that you
shouldn't cross the street which applies
when there are cars rules and laws are
our conditional you know they they they
are they're there to govern I said when
when you have a quarantine and no one's
really out driving in that particular
area at that time it's not essential for
me to follow this rule it's a stupid
rule but but I you know that's why I'm
not here oh I'm not here oh because I I
made a real-time judgment call to walk
across the street and I hear Oh a man
who's standing beside standing between
me and the breakdown of the civil order
decided to come up to me and his go-kart
or whatever he's [ __ ] driving around
in and he's like you know what he looked
like the way cops look would like the
flat top hair I mean you know just you
know the guy that just just barely got
the job on the foots why he doesn't have
a car that's why he's in the go-cart
he's extra angry he's gotta [ __ ] be
tough he's that guy
you know so he goes water your door and
I'm like I'm crossing the street I'm
crossing the street and he sucked good
points to the [ __ ] he's a good
Neanderthal he points to the [ __ ] red
you know I'm dealing with this monster
so he points to the red day and I go
yeah I know but there's no cars and he
goes wolves were rules that's what he
says he goes rules are rules and then he
goes go back to the other side of the
street I'm like what really
and he made me walk back to the other
side of the street I was on and stand
there and then wait and then he was
sizing me up giving me that weird look
like am I gonna put this guy in jail
or not and it's like this is the type of
attitude that these people have because
we we now call everybody's a hero and
we've we've decided that they are they
are standing between us and the
breakdown of civil society and that they
are they are now and they become brown
shirts very quickly they it's just in
their nature do they love every cop I
every guy I know that became a cop is
somebody who just loves he's either Celt
they're insecure people not all of them
but a lot of them are there's great cops
out there are really good detectives but
there's there's an element of the police
force which stems from deep insecurity I
know a lot of guys were like gonna be
like big athletes and then Twitter and
rotator-cuff another drive around Penn
Station and the little go-cart thing and
they're cops and like they're not happy
they're not happy that's not the way
they wanted like to work out doesn't
mean they're necessarily bad cops but
they're dicks and when they could be a
dick to you they're a [ __ ] dick okay
and this goes being a dick and you know
what I was trying to [ __ ] do I was
going to the Manhattan Beach Creamery
the ice cream shop to find out what
flavors were vegan and kido
that's what I was doing because I wanted
to bring ice cream to the nurses and the
doctors that's what I was doing I bought
a lot of ice before the nurses and the
doctors and then I realized it was
melting because it was 90 degrees I had
to eat it but I it was for the ER it was
for the heroes it was for the heroes the
popsicles were for the heroes and this
douche bag in his go-kart patrolling
Manhattan B I just I can see something
happening that's not good I can feel it
I can feel it in the scowls of the
people when someone doesn't have a mask
I can feel it you know the old has been
turned against the young now you know I
look 17 I'm 35 but I look like a
teenager I present like a healthy Tina
so I am getting scowls from people
because they're like you're flaunting
health privilege is gonna be next by the
way it was white privilege was male
privilege health privilege is coming get
ready for that if you're not 600 pounds
with 19 problems you're gonna be an
issue you're gonna be an issue
don't you come here do you have gangrene
on your foot then do shut your mouth I
only want to hear people wear tumors are
growing inside them as we speak that's
what's happening next that's gonna be
the new form of identity politics it'll
be as somebody on stage talking about
that they have 19 to murrs that's gonna
be the new version of Nanette I've got a
tumor I've got 14 tumors
they're called comorbidities they're
pre-existing that's the new it'll be
called pre-existing and and listen I
could be dead in a week from this virus
or a host of other things so I'm not I'm
not saying that this [ __ ] isn't serious
you shouldn't take it seriously but like
let the kids skateboard let him go to
the beach
maybe they don't live with all people a
lot of kids live with elderly people you
some of them don't some of them don't
listen man I don't know the best way
forward I said before I'm like if we
fling the doors open maybe there is a
lot of bloodshed and carnage I don't
know but this idea that we're gonna
close every public space and and force
people to not be the mental health
effects of telling people that can't be
in nature and they can't be in places
that genuinely calm them down and make
them better and they can't exercise and
they can't do things like that for years
what's the plan do you know bad domestic
violence's that's it's bad people are
whaling on their kids and their wife and
the MOA stations are going up is that
what they say you would think that's
another fixed personality trait
you would think that that's a IIIi would
think there's not too many people I
guess there's guys sitting around on
their couch going I'm gonna [ __ ] my
family if this doesn't end in a week I'm
gonna really get in everybody's [ __ ]
ass literally if this does not end in a
week there's guys looking at gavin
newsom and you're like you better lift
these restrictions cuz I'm about to go
room to room in this house with my dick
out I've never thought about it before
but I'm gonna start beating and
molesting my family if I cannot go out
and have a sit-down meal I want to sit
down and be served if not everybody's
getting raped in this family you would
think that that you think that's a fixed
personality trait apparently so much is
up for grabs in this in this environment
I didn't know that harrowing haunting
haunting but I don't like the direction
it's going in I don't like the direction
burgers are going in calm down with the
burgers the gourmet burger we got it we
got to put the brakes on it I had a
burger today which was good but the
caramelized onions and the smoky
Chipotle and there's nothing better than
a than a grizzly burger off a [ __ ]
grill in the backyard with a slice of
American yellow cheese on a little
potato bun a little bit of ketchup
there's nothing better than that
while toweling yourself off because you
just swam in a pool and you're sitting
there and you got the grass under your
feet you're just eating a burger and
maybe somebody else's yard you didn't
pay for anything you know because you
live in hell you don't have a setup like
this but you've made a friend you can
pretend it's your life for a few hours
on a Sunday that's great you don't you
don't need all the accoutrements you got
to calm down
there's nothing better than and that's
coming back the house parties are coming
back the summer barbecues are coming
back because people I don't think are
gonna be going out this summer the way
that they were people are going to be
you know they're gonna be in smaller
groups it's it's the summer to get a
friend get a friend many of you are
[ __ ]
get a [ __ ] friend get an idea get a
clue I would start [ __ ] looking at
that face but start scrolling that
Facebook where's the pool start
messaging people you have not spoke to
in six years it does not matter just say
I just want I want to know if
coronavirus has affected your family and
I and I just wanted to pray for you I
just wanted to pray for you whatever you
have to say to get in their good graces
you better do it you got two [ __ ]
months you got two months before it's
you know it's go time
you know this episode of the Tim Dillon
show is brought to you by sheath
underwear that's right sheath underwear
what makes she's underwear different
it's simple sheath underwear has a
special two pouch compartment that keeps
your twig and berries from sticking to
your inner thigh that's it
that's the idea and it's brilliant I've
tried it they've sent a bunch to me and
it's great my twig and berries are not
stuck to my inner thigh she's underwear
is made from a super comfortable blend
of modal and spandex it stretches as you
move and keeps you cool and dry I will
be honest it does keep you cool and it
does keep you dry I mean it really is
especially worth through a heatwave
right now and yeah I mean the balls
aren't such a lag it's it's everything's
great bunching pinching sagging doesn't
happen
she's underwear cradles your junk like a
mama gorilla holding her precious
newborn baby you know blade is half
human and half vampire this is a current
head huh you know blade kids hey kids
remember before Black Panther there was
one other black superhero and his name
was blade
he was played by Wesley Snipes she went
to jail on a tax lien charge Wesley had
the money but they probably just wanted
to make an example out of him
you know blade what blade he's a
half-human half-vampire they called him
day Walker day Walker that's racist shut
up so he gets the best of both worlds
being played well she's just like that
it's only combination of boxer briefs
and a jockstrap all of their powers none
of their weaknesses
the idea for sheath comes from its
founder US Army soldier Robert Patton
during his second tour in Iraq if it
works in the sun-blasted desert some
Iraq you'll know it'll work wherever you
live it's true AIDS tested in the war
zone folks support this awesome veteran
owned indie company whose founder is a
fan of this show good Robert Pattinson
tour in Iraq listen if your underwear
holds up in Iraq it'll hold up while
you're sitting in your house doing
nothing in the quarantine because it
gets hot your twig and your berries will
be protect have you ever heard it called
twig and berries so weird cuz like twigs
kind of demeaning said to meet no make
it small yeah yeah oh it's thin and
small like no but nobody's like yeah I'm
coming over there I got my twig you're
gonna handle my twig it's like it's a
nod that's kind of hard wait I can break
hey you hey you twig hey you got my big
twig here I got my twig and berries here
hanging out here like a [ __ ] a berry
twig tree here what are you gonna do hey
you want to take a look at my twig
support this veteran owned company we
should do more for veterans in this
country I've said it before and I'll say
it again go to sheath underwear calm in
order with promo code t IM to get 20%
off your first order she's under where's
money 100 money 100% money-back
guarantee that sheath underwear calm
which is SH EA th promo code Tim T I am
it's really good it's good underwear I
like it I have a bunch of
I appreciate it to have all kinds of
sizes it's shipped it comes right to
your door you're gonna love it it keeps
you dry if you liked this show and you
need underwear and you don't want to go
out right now go to a department store
many of them aren't open if you're
buying everything online now you're
buying the majority of your clothes
online now for the foreseeable future if
you liked the show and you need
underwear I'm telling you it's good
underwear and you don't have to walk
into a store and endanger yourself or
others so you go to sheath underwear
dot-com promo code TI m to get 20% off
your first order and you will like it I
I'm telling you it's good underwear you
need underwear unless you've gone
commando like a real freak you need
underwear and this is this is a safe way
to get it it's easy it's good it's
perfect sheath underwear dot-com promote
Cote I am
the Tim Dylan show is brought to you by
expressvpn expressvpn is great for
protecting your privacy and security
online but now that you're stuck at home
you can also use unlock foreign movies
and TV shows that are only available in
other countries binge doctor who on
Netflix in the United Kingdom or if
you're in a Japanese anime use it to
watch spirited away on Netflix in Japan
it's easy to use even for a guy like me
Saudi Arabian soap operas
get him Mongolian rom-coms go and get it
just open the app change your location
and that's it choose from a hundred
different countries expressvpn works on
any streaming service Netflix Amazon
Hulu BBC YouTube you name it to use it
the reason I use Express VPN and I don't
but the reason is I just don't even know
what it is it's a virtual private
network so you can't see what you're
doing right that's all point great
someone uses it I'm sure it works I
don't know what you're doing out there
no buffering or lag streaming HD without
an issue and it works on all your
devices any font tablet I'm gonna try it
because I want to I want to start
watching you know more shows from
Pakistan but if you're cool the VPN is
cool you can you can play games you can
do other [ __ ] you know I'm sure wouldn't
you
uses one and all the work she does and
stuff like that so if you're journalists
if you want to look into cool [ __ ] if
you want to read cool stuff if you want
to find out about stuff for that being
on a [ __ ] government watch list it's
probably a good [ __ ] idea right
probably a really good idea get on the
dark web get on the dark web you get
yourself a few oxycotin mmm okay take
the edge off I'm kidding don't do that
don't do that you wouldn't do that
this is you you're using a VPN so you
can you can get Pakistani comedy if you
visit my special link right now
expressvpn comm slash Tim Dylan you can
get an extra three months if expressvpn
for free listen it is a good idea right
now you're being tracked wherever you
are online so if VPN a lot of people use
it because they just don't want to be
tracked I don't really care about being
tracked I mean I should care but I just
don't you know everything like Google is
like I just hit someone from GrubHub
what what does that mean I asked what
does that mean I have like you know
what's that word with the e to crisis
what I'm thinking about it's like hey
I'm having a it's like a you a crisis of
who you are and everything existential
crisis so after I hit someone from doing
that
I just fought with someone physically
from door - what does that mean
but VPN you know you get it you get it
it protects your privacy it's so
important it's so important to protect
your privacy so important because you
wanna you know you don't want to be
giving up those all your goods you don't
want to you don't want to show people
where your head's at this government's
collecting all the information so
expressvpn calm slash Tim Dell most
people are gonna be using VPNs in the
future as the government gets more
totalitarian and it's just collecting
all your information is tracking every
[ __ ] minute of the day chip in your
neck
did you break quarantine blah blah blah
did you coughed did you sneeze did just
that fall all the security stuffs coming
to the verge of the VPNs man they're all
gonna be insane
important it disguises where you are the
government doesn't know and a lot of
cool journalist that we've had on the
show use them support the show watch
what you want we'll do it on the show
will get for the next ad will use this
and will will get a fun show will get
like a fun but I don't want like Doctor
Who or anime I want like I wanna watch I
wanna watch like a fun like Saudi shell
you know something fun some fun support
the show watch what you want expressvpn
comm slash Tim Dylan that is TI m TI ll
o n go and [ __ ] just you know do what
you want to do folks get your privacy
back you got to buy it back
you got to buy your privacy back but
it's better than nothing a lot of people
making making adjustments Ben was gonna
have a wedding bended to chose not to
have his wedding when was the date of
your wedding
April 25th so Ben chose to surrender his
civil rights and not have his wedding
and it was in the state of Texas he
could have showed up with his fiance and
guns because they you know they're
really only accountable to the Lord but
he chose them now he doesn't get a
wedding present because of that and you
understand why right now you've
explained to me I've explained it to but
now other people have sent in your
wedding present I have yeah most have
most I mean mo mo most most people are
animals like they crawl no you don't get
a wedding present without a wedding it's
not the way it works you don't get a
birthday present without a birthday you
don't get a graduation present without a
[ __ ] graduation party and and by the
way if if if you know they're doing a
new show did you hear this by the way
did you hear this because I'm convinced
now and I almost think this is hilarious
I think the big studio heads and the
people that are making decisions in
Hollywood are show Republican or
conservative behind the scenes that the
new things are doing or they're almost
trolling with the new shows that they
are
coming up with go to the Hollywood
Reporter's Twitter I love this new show
that is coming out is if if the Trump
campaign wanted an ad a perfect ad keep
going down you'll find it if they wanted
an ad it would be this show it would be
this show
it absolutely is up here it is now keep
going down I mean it's one of those
things where it is it's like the
imagined video but a show it's like
somebody who watched the imagined video
and said you know what what if this
could happen every week
I mean it's so [ __ ] crazy how much
does The Hollywood Reporter tweet yeah
we're like 10 hours in the timeline here
with 10 hours in the timeline this
[ __ ] some Hollywood shut down how I
mean how much can they [ __ ] tweet what
the five mean dude this is who runs a
Hollywood Reporter's Twitter account
somebody on cocaine of course somebody
doing blow alright so here we go this is
the the Trump campaign out here listen
to this
Fox Fox makes you think Fox is greenlit
ten episodes of an unscripted series
called celebrity watch party which as
its name implies will feature famous
people in their homes discussing the
biggest shows and news events on TV in
the past week I mean are you [ __ ]
insane are you [ __ ] insane we are in
a pandemic we've got 30 million people
unemployed we're on the [ __ ] brink of
a great depression and you're going to
have a show where celebrities sit in
their mansions and discuss the news of
the day are you do you want Trump to
ever be out of office I mean do you just
want Trump to become Putin and just not
leave because that's where we're
celebrity watch party is set to premiere
May 7th with its debut episode featuring
Rob
low meghan trainor Joe Buck Raven Symone
master pian Romeo Joe Josie WA Steve
Wozniak Curtis Stone Robert and Kim hurt
her Java core Javik I'm gonna give money
to Candice Owen soon do you mean do you
understand where I'm at now
I'm very very close just giving serious
money to Candice Owens and bringing her
on this program listen to this studio
lampert CEO Stephen Lambert limp air
whatever we're delighted so many famous
people love the idea of this show and
want to be a part of it it's a show
which asserts the indispensable role of
TV in the fabric of people's lives
and the way it's at the heart of the
nation's weekly conversations especially
in these unusual times huh it asserts
the indispensable role of TV in the
fabric of people's lives
what and the way it's at the heart of
the nation that these people are so
[ __ ] out of it that they think people
give a [ __ ] about what Raven Symone has
to say about the [ __ ] kovat 19 is
anyone sitting at home going what is
Meghan Trainor have to say hey where's
Rob Lowe on ventilators hey hey where's
master P on REM des aveer does anyone
know if master P and Romeo have anything
to say about hydroxychloroquine what
about celebrity chef Curtis Stone does
he have an idea
what does Curtis Stone think about
Biden's sexual accuser terrine hey Steve
Wozniak you think BA you think Biden put
a finger in what the [ __ ] is wrong they
I mean so what is the show dude there
might have been a high-level Illuminati
meeting in ha
with that said listen if Trump's not
reelected we have nothing I mean dude
there I'm not even [ __ ] kidding there
might have been a high-level Illuminati
meeting in Hollywood where they went
everything has gone up since he's been
elected and everything was failing
before that including Twitter SNL news
programs comedy programs lots of a late
night shows Colbert lots of our landmark
properties they've all grown
tremendously in the era of Trump he
cannot lose if Biden comes in we're
[ __ ]
we need Trump to win and they're all
sitting there and they're you know it's
some some bel-air mansion they're all
sitting there they're smoking cigars or
whatever in there they're looking at
each other and they're like how do we
how do we guarantee the Trump wins again
and they go what if what if there was a
show where Raven Symone talked about
coronavirus from a mansion with like Rob
Lowe and and Master P and just
celebrities like you're like what if
every week we went to a celebrity's home
and a state and then film them on their
couch discussing the news of the day and
they're all like you're all kind of like
you know sniff there's a brandy they're
like this is kind of a good idea they're
like but we need them to talk about more
than pop culture like you have to talk
about the news yes and then one guy goes
and they don't know anything about the
news but they'll have a bunch of
offensive opinions yes and we need them
without any of their handlers we can't
really be scripted they need to have
just crazy off-the-cuff takes and half
makes sense they have to be annoyingly
liberal and completely out of touch and
if we do that week after week we can
pretty much guarantee that Donald walks
right back into that office and we sit
right back I'm telling you right now I'm
telling you right now I know this is
conspiracy thinking but I'm not that
wrong this doesn't make sense this show
does not make sense this is crazy this
is genuinely crazy and something is
behind this
if it's a brilliant Republican mole in
[ __ ] one of these networks
Bravo hats off because I didn't even see
the show yet I read the description The
Hollywood Reporter and I'm about to give
I'm about to take all the money out of
my bank account and give it to Kansas
Owens I'm about to give the money and
sponsor a Candace Owens goes on tour
calling the virus fake after after
seeing this [ __ ] thing they don't
learn these people they don't learn Bush
George W Bush learned he paints silently
in his house in Texas and he just chills
and every now and then he pops up with
Ellen somewhere uh at a you know a
football stadium you know while he's
passing a message along to her from
whatever the [ __ ] those two were
involved in I mean I'm telling you right
now folks something real weird about a
show like that kind of interesting TV's
not at the heart of anyone's [ __ ]
life can you stop the fabric of their
life it's not everybody's online now
everybody watches everything on [ __ ]
YouTube yes occasionally people watch
the masked singer and shows like that
yes TV has more resonance than I would
expect in Middle America but the
majority of people are online it's very
funny to think about it's very very
interesting you know but you know we
move on we move on folks to to bigger
and better things to greater things you
know we will we will all make it through
this and by all of us I mean 18% of us
roughly eighteen to twenty percent we
can't really tease the thing we're gonna
maybe launch right we can't do that huh
no okay good good but I didn't want to
get into this Jim I did want to talk
about a few other things I mean that
that Hollywood sure I mean that's at MIT
that's just simply amazing to
but that's what happens you know I mean
this is what happens what people don't
learn their lesson it's just it's just
like fat people fat people don't learn
there let's why they stay fat it's just
you don't learn your lesson as a fat
person I can speak from authority on
that is you don't learn your fat people
don't learn their lesson fat people
don't get to have control they don't get
to make choices any and I've said I
talked about this before on the show
know every diet to market yourself to
fat people that's like it's your choice
and there's so many choice it's like no
fat people are fat because they make the
wrong choices take away their power of
choice they should get no choice you
know who had no choice the kids that
worked in work houses and they ate gruel
none of them were fat because they
didn't have a bountiful harvest of
choices we don't need an America we have
this bountiful harvest you know if
people are say to me the other day
they're like why is art like why is so
much of it garbage and it's like well
how much great art comes out of a
country with 400 kinds of cheesecake how
deep are people really digging in
themselves when there's 400 kinds of
cheesecake you can name a hundred kinds
of cheesecake off the top of your head
right now if you had if you had to write
down seventy kinds of cheesecake 80
kinds of cheesecake it would take maybe
ten minutes and you could write it down
easily easily okay you could barely name
one healthcare company you'd be like
Blue Cross Blue Shield and then they'd
be like okay and then you'd be like ah
but you can name Stephanie Khadijah so
yeah it's like how much arts really
gonna have you even been to anything in
quarantine I watched the Americans which
is a great show which again made by
action any that yeah well it's made by
accident everything good in this country
happens by accident it's made by
accident they everything should be santa
clarita diet like everything in this
country should be a show about zombies
where people have which straight faces
have to say this is a show about
drew barrymore eating clams from Serbia
and turning into a zombie and eating
people in her neighborhood that's what
every show in this country should be but
occasionally by accident they make the
Sopranos or the wire or breaking bed but
it's it's primarily santa clarita diet
which is about a zombie who eats people
in Santa Clarita California that's the
show and I even watch some of it you
know and I watch them a bit and some of
it wasn't horrible it was kind of a fun
I'm not saying every show has to be good
but that's where the majority of things
are they just they take an idea and they
just dumb it down because they're the
Hollywoods opinion of Americans and
they're not all wrong but Hollywood's
opinions of Americans are like shapeless
blobs that can't really move and can't
really speak and just kind of sit in
couches and go like this yeah like
that's what Hollywood thinks Americans
are just shapeless beast people that
just eat like frozen food in the
container they don't even heat it up in
their microwave they just start gnawing
on it they just eat fast food
hollywood's american viewer is a 600
pound shapeless mass of flesh sitting in
a throne made of fast-food wrappers with
a [ __ ] maggot on that's what
Hollywood thinks everyone in America is
so they go what will be interesting for
them oh let's do a show bad sound did
they like eating then they're like well
the word diets in the title that'll turn
some of them off you know but we as soon
as as soon as we can convey to them that
it's about eating people that's my santa
clarita diet all of the things about it
were like a hand in a mulch orsa because
then people like oh this is it a show
about eating cucumbers it's about people
eating each other I'll watch that have
you been binging anything during the
quarantine that's that's been good I got
into better call Saul and you said it's
as good as Breaking Bad now that
most people would disagree with you but
I'm I told you I'm like on the 13th
episode you said it starts to fall off
but Bob Odenkirk is very good I do like
the shows what do you think he's giving
you a job he is great he's great
no he's not giving me a job giving
anyone a job I lunched with the guy runs
his production company thanks for the
lunch by the way appreciated that it's
good you know it's one of those lunches
in LA they go yeah well uh good luck
with every it's nice I get it I get it
I have a lot of lunches people go
because I think people like the idea of
me
yeah so they want to go out with me and
talk about ideas it'll you know it just
is what it is and then when it's time to
like actually do a thing they go no no
no no that's art because I might say
something funny that's the biggest
problem in my career is that I wasn't
asked to do any of these coronavirus
benefits by the way listened to what I
was gonna do this is funny
all of these cron of it they asked
Norman they have Sam Morril great comics
but they don't ask me ah now here's
what's fun this is guys do you see the
humor in this I get asked to do the
coronavirus benefit and my bit because I
don't believe this but my bit my
reoccurring bit is that I think the
virus is fake and I think the nurses are
actors and I keep bringing that up
during the benefit and I keep suggesting
that we storm the hospital with weapons
now as a bit because I'm a comedian
that's hilarious
that is it is hilarious to go say
something heartfelt your your celebrity
comedian say something heartfelt about
why we should support the coronavirus
people and I'm gonna tell you why my
idea would have been great and they
missed out on what could have been a
great bet I've seen a lot of stories on
the internet about nurses their faces
have welts and sores on them from the
mass they're working 18-hour shifts
they're very tired we need to reach out
to these people and provide support and
this time of need I appreciate that I
think we have to really start asking the
tough questions about this disease and
about those marks on their faces
specifically and where those marks came
from and if those marks could have come
from makeup
so I know that a lot of people are
donating tonight to help the nurses and
the doctors but I just want to ask you a
question I want to ask you a question
out there if this is a real pandemic and
people are really sick why do I Drive by
hospitals and not see bodies burning on
the street it would have been it would
have been a lot of fun but of course no
one can have any fun right nobody can
have any fun anymore all we have is fun
folks the economy is just fun that's all
that's left is being a goof folks how
many times how many times have I told
you that your life can change it doesn't
have to be this way you don't have to be
that loser you see in the mirror you can
be a winner you have to stop losing and
start winning you have to hustle you
have to grind you have to kill it but
most importantly you have to crush it
are you crushing it are you killing it
as our friend mr. Van your Chuck would
say maybe you don't because you don't
have a ridge wallet the ridge wallet is
at minimal front pocket wall that's
designed to streamline what you carry
every day very easy to sanitize it's a
small metallic wallet forces you to take
only the most important things credit
card debit card lawyers card maybe a
hundred dollar bill it forces you to
streamline and organize yourself very
easy to sanitize very easy folks
comes in titanium carbon fiber aluminum
over a dozen different styles and colors
but super easy when you're hand
sanitizing you sanitize your Ridge
doesn't get wet like a leather wallet
and gross Kovan spores living everywhere
when you were sanitizing your hand you
put your
Ridge wallet in between both hands and
you sanitize the ridge and now you are
both sanitizing your wallet in your
hands this is this is new we're living
in a new world now get 10% off free
worldwide shipping and returns they're
so confident that you're gonna like it
they give you free returns by going to
Ridge comm slashed Mt I am Ridge comm
slash Tim CIA my father bought a bunch
of them it didn't use the [ __ ] promo
code because everyone in my family tries
to destroy me at every moment okay but
they've they've been unsuccessful
because I've canceled or canceled your
family tour back 2027 wait for it I'm a
monster
amidst the fires of a fallen world can't
see family tour will be back isn't that
good how totally wrong was the name of
my tour cancer your family than a
disease literally cancels your family
it's like my next tour is gonna be
called oops get 10% off today folks
ships all over the world we got fans in
every country don't we Ben dare we do
yeah good I mean this Ben uses a ridge
wallet we both do
I don't really use a wallet I'm above a
wallet a little due respect I have
people wire I have a wire is happening I
have people wiring money from the Cayman
Islands
I have bank accounts on small islands I
don't need a wallet I don't do cash I am
- debit cards I have assistants I've
personal I have everything
I'm um I am a multi-trillion and what's
above trillion look at what's about
chillin is it zillion or the gazillion
it zillion Orange quadrillion what is
zillion find zillion for me now because
that's what I am
Cillian isn't fake a zillion a number
I think it's fictitious did I just get
outed on the show for everyone no yeah
it doesn't exist
[ __ ] all right I don't really I don't
have anything but I'll have more you get
the rich wallet I thought I I thought
it's gonna say I was ill Ian Ayre I
thought it was a number but it's
actually not I should have said
quadrillion doc you got snot coming out
of your nose through this carpet makes
my nose run
maybe it's the [ __ ] covetous coursing
through your body you [ __ ] carrier
halfway through every episode my nose
just right now it's the woods two rug
when you get it cleaned it's like the
line for the Albert Brooks wouldn't we
need to the music we need to get a cream
he goes by we you mean me right he's
great I'm [ __ ] the ridge wallet you
know so go to Ridge comm slash Tim use
the code TI m link in description it's a
great wallet it's easy to sanitize and
I'm telling you 100% it's a great thing
you you need to simplify it's a [ __ ]
pandemic you can't be too complicating
your life you need a wallet you can
easily just sanitize you know what I
mean it really is I'm telling you right
now it's actually a good buy and it's
actually a smart buy right now so rich
calm slash Tim and use cote IM link
description remember to use the code
thank you
you know the other thing is like you're
gonna now they're gonna have this
celebrities give the kids graduations be
by the way here's the thing with the
graduation speeches folks there's never
been a time in our society where the
graduation speech is meant less okay
information is everywhere if your kid
wants information they can get it
informations been democratized college
is kind of a scam now like there's
definitely a more cost-effective way to
do college but the idea of like somebody
like what like the people that are
giving these kids like commencement
speeches are like jimmy fallon
and Alan it's like and like the CEOs of
companies it's like guys that's not
gonna help you out right now we're
heading towards a world that's gonna
look very differently you need to have a
homeless person give the commencement
speech at the college so that a lot of
these kids are gonna know what's
happening
they literally need a homeless man to
get up there with with with with with
like like a via like a Vietnam vet
homeless guy to get up there who's like
to shoes but like they're both got a
falling off and he's dirty
and he's [ __ ] you know he asks for a
cigarette before he starts and you give
him a cigarette and he's like it's
[ __ ] what is this man well where are
we and then he goes into it he tells you
the real [ __ ] you know tells you real
[ __ ] he goes I went to Vietnam and
country doesn't give a [ __ ] I came back
I started [ __ ] his hooker we had a
kid you know who we bought a house she
went insane cuz there's no mental health
care in the country
she burned the house down I ran out with
my two children in the street luckily
our neighbor was one of these Christian
freaks she was a real freak and was kind
of annoying but she took me and my kids
in that night my wife is dead because
she burned the house down because she
didn't get any mental health care and
she was hooking because she was molested
by her father who ironically was in the
church was a deacon not a priest but a
deacon I used to bless his daughter
that's probably why she liked me she
liked fucked-up men that's just the way
it is so we started [ __ ] and she was
fertile I mean she was Porto Rican I
mean [ __ ] fertile they just [ __ ] out
kids these Puerto Ricans and we had two
of these [ __ ] and then she
burnt the [ __ ] house down in the
middle of the night I I was pretty
[ __ ] up I'm not gonna lie I'd been on
a coke bender for like three days I'm
pretty drunk so what happened was I felt
the flames they were touching my feet
knife I woke up and I'm like I hope my
kids aren't burned I hope they're not
burned so I ran into there
and they were sleeping like angels I
mean literal angels it was the only
moment I believed in God and as soon as
I had that awakening where I believed in
God I thought immediately of the devil
because I saw the flames that's the
duality of man isn't it the duality of
life God in the devil and then I ran
outside and my ass was still kind of hot
because the flames caught onto my jeans
and I was always like breathing fire
because I was drinking whiskey that
night trying to get to sleep there to
the coke peddler so I'm in the middle of
the street half-naked with these two
kids their mother is being burned to
death in the house the fire department
didn't come because we live in the
[ __ ] Bronx so they waited for the
[ __ ] whole house to go up so then
finally my [ __ ] freak Christian
neighbor comes out took my kids in got
them closed those kids went into foster
care went to the state they found me
later told me I [ __ ] up their whole
life one of them's in jail the other
one's somewhere out on the [ __ ]
Street man I had a security coward job
for like half a year in 96 I don't
really know what's been happening since
anyway so I just want to say to the
class of 2020 that you know just onward
and upward brighter things are ahead and
you know a lot of people and these
things my saying the most important
lesson I've learned and the most
important lesson I've learned in my life
is kind of did you just say [ __ ] you
know and then he would light a cigarette
and then he leaves the digital
graduation and then that's really that's
a grand then just stunned stunned
soulless
tick-tock youth in their [ __ ] rooms
with their parents their [ __ ] parents
[ __ ] in their mouths again some of them
giggling some of them floored staring at
each other being like what the [ __ ] just
happened
that would be so much of a more valuable
commencement speech than some [ __ ]
celebrity who's there to talk about how
you just have to keep going and then
eventually Lauren Michaels will see
enough with that [ __ ] tell them what it
really is tell them what they wore
on bill gates does a speech he goes
there's a needle under everyone's chair
it's already picked you in the ass we're
gonna see how now you hole we're gonna
see here during my speech we're gonna
study your reactions and see what
happened is the vaccine coming we don't
know folks we don't know maybe it's
colleague it's kind of a fantasy the
more I read about it the more the idea
of a vaccine to a virus like this in any
type of reasonable amount of time seems
like a fantasy
also the antiviral drugs almost seemed
like a fantasy I mean listen I'm not I'm
not a doctor
not a virologist I'm not an immunologist
I don't work in the pharmaceutical
industry but from what I've heard what I
can tell this seems to be something that
we might have to learn kind of live with
we might have to mitigate its effects
somehow figure out a way to deal with
this treated like a seasonal flu if
that's at all possible doctors gonna
learn about this and learn how to treat
it but I do think we're edging
inevitably towards a conflict with China
I don't know how that conflict is gonna
is gonna manifest but I think it's
coming a lot of us and in other
countries they're there their companies
or manufacturing is leaving China China
was a hub for manufacturing all the jobs
that left America went to China and you
know man
just is what it is I just want to chose
to inject a little dose of reality into
a world that I think you know there's a
lot of money to not be there's there's
far there's so much more money in
[ __ ] on this planet there's so much
more money in it which is understandable
but you know I just think it would be
funny to have a homeless Vietnam veteran
to all the cob by the way no no everyone
gets the same every college gets the
same speech and it's this one guy it's
just one [ __ ] guy and he does the
speech every single college gets the
same speech every group of kids all
these yeah I see my friend's little
brothers and sisters they're like yeah
roll tide or Alabama's like well we'll
see we'll see
I don't know if schools gonna be back in
there in September I hope so because if
not ever one's gonna be beaten and raped
that's I mean that's apparently what's
going on there's just beatings and
molestations going on if a family has to
sit together in the house for more than
48 hours dad gets a little weird yeah my
dad had never displayed any inclination
towards that kind of behavior but I are
around week three of the quarantine he
started getting weird you know he
started getting odd you know he started
just playing incest porn on the family
TV and asking us if we liked it if we
didn't he used to just beat the [ __ ] out
of us up until this he'd been a great
dad but this is what happens this is
what happens when somebody can't go out
have a nice sit-down meal mm-hmm it's a
problem food is not meant to be take out
you're not meant to eat out of boxes and
bags like a dog you're not meant to do
it you not met all these high-end
restaurants or did you take out you're
not meant to eat a ribeye out of the tin
you're not meant to eat a ribeye out of
a tin for the love of God
it's a [ __ ] tin you meant to eat
Chinese food and pizza takeout not even
sushi barely sushi I know you'll love
takeout and I eat it too
but it's not meant you're meant to dine
like a person the food should go from
the pan to the plate to your mouth
indirectly in a reasonable amount of
time now everything can't be putting a
tent in a bag for you you slurp it out
like a dog [ __ ] Mastro's master
stakeouts that Beverly Hills is running
a human trafficking ring we got rid of
swingers they're done now
sorry swingers sorry your vegan nuggets
or whatever the [ __ ] you was serving
that faux retro embarrassing diner and
your tattooed staff a [ __ ] Avril
Lavigne wannabes or whoever the hell
they thought they were gonna be enough
they thought they were the Pixies or
something the staff walking around now
Hey
calm it down calm it down and get the
omelet please stop Lee you're not living
in LA cool life stop okay
oh my life's like a movie no it's not
it's it's not like a movie it's very
much like the I don't have a my omelette
that's what your life is like put a
smile on your face
stop being brooding and dark and complex
you've not a thought in your head you
have not a thought in your head I mean
is X really about hey shut up
I get the cake I feel bad that they
closed but I missed a meatloaf that good
turkey meatloaf but the reality of the
situation is I was in a war with them
and I was in a war with that don't go he
restaurants don't go to war with me
don't go to war with me it's not a good
move not a good move bad things seem to
happen to the restaurant cuz I know I
know what's gonna happen there's certain
restaurants I love Craig's in Beverly
Hills phenomenal they've been delivering
food and it's been phenomenal you know I
think they have a bright future but
swingers not good
they didn't treat people nicely they
treated people they did not you know I
went in one day this is a famous old
episode we did called the big booth you
can I went and I said I want to sit at a
bigger booth and they didn't let me and
there was no one in the restaurant they
said because you have to have a you have
to have a group of six to sit at that
and I was like oh you're just like the
cop in Manhattan Beach you're enforcing
rules that don't make sense you're a
brown shirt you're a brown shirt you're
a Nazi and I don't like Nazis that's not
they're not nice I like people who are
accommodating and you're not being
accommodating so swears was is gone now
and it's gone sorry but I'm gonna open a
restaurant I'm gonna do it in LA cuz New
York it's a lot of good restaurants
maybe not after that but I will open a
restaurant in Los and I'm looking for
investors and here's a reality if you
have a lot of money
give it
to me and let me open a restaurant I
know I know what I'm doing I will make
it good I will make it good I know how
to do it I know all the ins and outs of
the business and I know I know what has
to happen I know why people like
restaurants you know I you know all
right man I could have I could have
saved swingers it's just a little faux
retro diner on Melrose in LA man I could
save that place if they sat down and I
said they if they said what should we do
Tim how do we do it how do we how do we
how do we do it I would have [ __ ] told
the man I would I would absolutely told
them how to do it you know absolutely I
would take his staff put him in burkas
had to tell burkas you want to win in
this town you gotta [ __ ] you gotta
you gotta you gotta go hard in the wool
paint head-to-toe burkas head-to-toe
only small slits for the eyes and
everybody I don't care how hot it is
head-to-toe black burkas men and women
there are no genders it's a genderless
restaurant gendered language is banned
gendered language is bad all the food is
halal
it is it is an homage to Islam which was
a religion that loves homosexuals and
transgender people
it's what the movies seem like that's
Hollywood so we have we have people in
burkas and then also we have just gay
icons on the wall Harvey Milk
RuPaul gay icons Jonathan Larson who
wrote rent oh no he's an icon an op it's
a great show she's gay icons on the wall
everyone in a burqa you know I could
have saved it if they asked me nobody
asked me
nobody nobody came to me and said Tim
how do you how do you turn this around I
know how to turn it around I know if
you're a restaurant you're failing is
because you don't have an Instagram Abul
dish
if basic white [ __ ] are not pulling
out their phones to take a photo of
something in your restaurant
you're going to fail you are going to
fail
white women need to take photos of a
dish and spread it around that needs to
happen or you're in trouble the boomers
are now on tik toks is the pandemic
they've all discovered ticked it's got
to be fun to see how they can be racist
on tick-tock it's gonna be interesting
to see how my aunt can figure out how to
be racist on tick-tock how is she gonna
come up with a dance that shows that she
harbors a lot of you know unsavory ideas
how can she show in a dance and a themed
dance that she believes you know that
women who've had abortions should be
committed how can she do that in a
tick-tock seemed danced be interesting
to see huh you just seem to see how she
could show a commitment to a radical
Catholicism on tick-tock through it
themed dance you know how could she show
us her pro-family values dance her
pro-trump stance you know she loves she
loves Trump politics is sports for
people that are just older yeah just get
in this politics because there's not
life life has a few stages of it and the
final one and it starts for peope some
people it starts at 19 but the final
stage of life is really the spectator
stage you're no longer participating
you're you the job is gonna be the job
the family Arrangements gonna be the
family arrangement so you slide into the
spectator phase of your life which I
never hope to do I hope I never do that
I hope maybe I will
hopefully I mean it's some very
successful people get there a lot of
unsuccessful people get there to suspect
enter stage go back you recline on the
lazy boy
and you engage with people about
meaningless horseshit to just to just by
the time until there's a cancer with
growth that the doctors can't do
anything about then they zap you know
we're all just racing till the end here
there isn't we don't get saved you know
we don't there's no eternal
consciousness certainly not for us
you know not for you people your [ __ ]
income bracket they're not gonna freeze
you they're gonna put you know your
conscience is not gonna be uploaded to
the mainframe you're out you're out of
here it's kind of happen it's gonna be
some somebody gonna get ya so until then
you know there's stages of life there's
yeah I see them I was that man hot Beach
see the young kids that are in their
late teens
they're like to dream like wonder like
stage of life and don't don't with them
not all of them some of them are in
private prison I know but a lot of them
are in and they're in the dream like
wonder like anything's possible
everything is in front of you it's a
great stage of your life it isn't real
because the things you think are
possible are actually not but you don't
know that yet because you don't know
yourself yet I thought I was gonna be
like a Navy SEAL or something I thought
I was gonna number one not only what I
do I not want to do any physical work I
don't what like I'm not what I'm gonna
go and pretend to kill bin Laden like
stop I you know I thought it's gonna be
you know like in the government I was
gonna work cuz I liked being on debate
team you know you don't know yourself
when you're 16 or 17 you barely know
yourself but that's the dream like
wonder like phase of whatever and then
as you get older
get in your 20s in the 20s is like the
work worki phase where you're like
you're excited to work you Excel work is
exciting in your twenty jobs can be
exciting getting somewhere is exciting
you're figuring out your love life
you're figuring out what you do you know
you're figuring it all out and you're
figuring out who you are in your
twenties and what you want out of life
now in your 30s you're figuring out
really who you're not so you figure out
in your 30s who you're not ya ain't
gonna work that hard I'm
not really gonna be that nice to my
brother I'm not really gonna call my
parents as much I should I'm not gonna
take this bitch's mouth I don't give a
[ __ ] you start figuring out who you're
not and you're 30 you start to be like
you know hey and then eventually you
just you get to a point you know where
you are just a spectator and that's a
lot of people you see on Facebook
they're fighting back and forth
it's a spectator sport life has just
been distilled into like a clever postal
Elath well do you know it Trump canceled
the chill from chess to him what are you
doing and then the person goes back I
gave him a memo we need in dude what did
he do with the tar and it's like you
guys are fighting about nothing it's
literally nothing I mean there's nothing
to go forward if you think that's the
end the answer if you still think that's
the answer
god bless you and go do it I'll fold you
pull that lever pull the liver in the
local library roll the scary drag queens
are reading sure one of them will show
you
I'm sure ginger will show you where the
voting is in the library and you pull
the lever and you go home and and then I
sit back and you sit there and you glory
sit there after your candidate wins and
sit there in your glory sit there and
really enjoy the glorious victory that
you've won you rode into town on horse
on horseback and you just murdered all
the man and [ __ ] all the women and now
you're just sitting here with all the
gold all the gold enjoy it but I mean
stop stop bickering with people it's
stupid
I see smart people doing it and they're
like well this is fun it's not that fun
you know I talked to one of my friends
about it like
you fighting all the time because I like
it it's fun I'm like it's not what it
what why get another hobby get another
get another sport fighting on Facebook
it's ultimately you're not no one's mind
is being changed by 300 comments thread
on Facebook no one cares
just walk away through the happiest
people I know are people that are so
disconnect disconnect live your own life
live a life that's not being given to
you in an algorithm by Mark Zuckerberg
literally live that life live a life was
that isn't being designed for you by
people in Palo Alto live a life like
things that aren't being recommended to
you by you know nameless faceless
technocrats have actual friends you
speak to over the phone or in person I
mean you know I don't know what to tell
you you know if you see that cop see
that cop in Manhattan Beach Tommy's a
hero you tell him he's a hero because
there's nothing I like more than telling
telling telling a cop who's risking his
life risking his life to stop a fat guy
halfway across the street and make him
go back to the other side of the street
he could be in Compton it Watts give me
places he could be Van Nuys he could be
a place with actual problems but he's in
in in in in Manhattan Beach which is an
idyllic seaside paradise driving around
on a go-cart guarding the ice cream shop
and he thinks he's a hero and he thinks
he's protecting you and he thinks that
he stands behind you and in the
dissolution of society that's a problem
and I don't know how it can be fixed and
probably can't but that's one of the
reasons we need to figure out a way to
live with this [ __ ] virus I don't
know
how we're gonna do it but we got to
figure out a way to live with the virus
because I can't have a cop driving
around a idyllic beautiful seaside
paradise eating a popsicle thinking that
he's a [ __ ] hero you're not a hero
you're not a hero we should do that in
society what so so we bang the pans for
the heroes what do we do for the non
heroes what do we do for the people that
are heroes should they get anything
should they get any acknowledgment maybe
they're heroes in training maybe they
maybe they just need a few a few hits on
the pan to become a hero
well we're ignoring them but I hope this
I hope this lockdown begins to come to
an end
I hope but I hope it does because if it
does it if the lockdown doesn't come to
an end I don't know many things I don't
have many things but I know that a lot
of women are gonna be pregnant with
their fathers baby good night and good
luck